[Musica]
otto secondi è la media della nostra
attenzione oggi esattamente la durata
della frase che avete appena sentito
abbiamo un'attenzione che è più bassa
della sua un pesce rosso che cela appare
un secondo più lunga della nostra
in realtà questo confronto impietoso
l'hanno fatto gli studiosi della
microsoft canada nel 2015 che è stato
vero devo dire per onestà intellettuale
molto contestato perché qualcuno si è
preso anche la briga di dire che come
fai a capire l'attenzione di un pesce
rosso stai davanti alla bolla lo guardi
li fai ciao ciao con la manina finché
quello si stufa se ne va quindi io credo
che fosse più una provocazione mi hanno
parlato tutti tutti i giornali al mondo
e alla fine quel pesce rosso è diventato
la metafora di quello che siamo noi oggi
dei distratti cronici e guardate la
parola distrazione non vuole dire
soltanto andare dietro a perdersi dietro
a qualcosa di irrilevante ma anche ed è
il significato più antico di questa
parola esplodere andare in mille pezzi
che è esattamente quello che sta
succedendo a noi oggi che rimbalziamo in
continuazione da uno stimolo all'altro e
passato circa un minuto da quando ho
cominciato e so che adesso tutti
avresti la tentazione di guardare sul
telefono se vi è arrivato un messaggio
una notifica di me di facebook lo so vi
capisco
lo farei anch'io non posso ma non fatelo
e ma non vi preoccupate anche perché è
normale è normale perché la
professoressa gloria mark
dell'università della california di
irvine ce l'ha spiegato lei da dieci
anni cronometra e monitora con
un'entomologa proprio
il tempo che noi passiamo davanti ad uno
schermo prima di essere distratti da un
altro dispositivo là dove per contratto
per definizione dovremmo essere più
attenti
cioè in ufficio sapete qual è il nostro
tempo massimo
davanti ad un monitor quando siamo al
lavoro cioè quando siamo pagati per
stare davanti a un monitor tre minuti
tre minuti dieci anni fa quando gli
smartphone
erano appena entrati nella nostra vita
sei anni fa eravamo scesi a un minuto e
15 secondi
adesso siamo passati a 40 secondi
vuoi dire che ogni 40 secondi noi
dobbiamo ri focalizzare la nostra
attenzione su un device è un altro
dispositivo un computer un telefono e
questa non è una provocazione
questa è scienza il fatto è che noi
pensiamo tutti quanti che noi possediamo
semplicemente un cellulare
crediamo di poterlo gestire pensiamo che
questo telefono sia in tasca in ma la
nostra e non ci rendiamo conto che in
realtà questo affarino risucchia la
nostra attenzione anche quando non lo
guardiamo quando non ci arriva nessuna
notifica persino pensate quando è spento
lo hanno dimostrato questi ricercatori
dell'università della california di san
diego in uno studio che hanno chiamato
brain drain letteralmente prosciugamento
del cervello
pensate che il telefonino risucchia
nostra attenzione e ci impedisce abbassa
la nostra capacità di compiere un
compito anche semplice anche fosse
quello di seguire le istruzioni di una
ricetta è infatti loro hanno dato agli
studenti non un pollo da cucinare
a delle semplici operazioni calcolo e
hanno visto che su 800 partecipanti
quelli che hanno ottenuto i risultati
peggiori sono stati quelli che avevano
il telefonino nelle vicinanze anche se
non l'avevano mai guardato e questo
perché tutto il tempo noi pensiamo ci
arriverà un messaggio ci chiamerà
qualcuno che cosa vi sto perdendo
io credo che anche ulisse di questi
tempi sarebbe stato in serie difficoltà
a resistere a queste sirene anche perché
parliamo di qualcosa che a questi numeri
allora al mondo ci sono più telefonini
che spazzolini da denti e questo magari
ci fa un po sorridere ci fa sorridere
meno pensare che al mondo ci sono più
schede sim che esseri umani ci sono 708
miliardi di abbonamenti telefonici
contro 7,5 miliardi di persone tra
tablet pc e smartphone
stiamo ogni giorno online sei ore
vuol dire passare più di un terzo della
nostra vita su internet andare diciamo
online è come partecipare ad un buffet
enorme con portate specialità da tutto
il mondo
ho tutte gratis e tutte a portata di
click
noi ci preoccupiamo sempre giustamente
come società di dell'epidemia di obesità
forse dovremmo iniziare a preoccuparci
anche della nostra info obesità pensate
che al mondo ogni secondo la rete
produce l'equivalente di 28 milioni di
volumi e come se ogni secondo tre
biblioteche centrali nazionali di
firenze contemporaneamente entrassero in
casa nostra
ogni giorno del mondo viaggiano 150
miliardi di
il 66 miliardi di foto su instagram 42
miliardi di messaggi bocciata quindi se
a fine serata vi sentite un po la testa
pesante
sapete perché io personalmente ho capito
che la situazione era fuori controllo
quando quest'estate tim cook il ceo di
apple
il numero uno della società che ha
inventato lo smartphone
la prima società peraltro americana ad
avere raggiunto una capitalizzazione di
un trilione di dollari cioè mille
miliardi di dollari ha affermato
sì stiamo esagerando con i nostri device
grazie a tim
grazie che ti sei arrivato il punto è
che noi passiamo da una chat social a un
link
magari mentre parliamo mentre lavoriamo
mentre studiamo come se fosse la cosa
più naturale del mondo più normale
perché ad un certo punto ci siamo tutti
convinti di essere multitasking
spero di poter fare più cose alla volta
anzi ci sembra anche molto smart vero
esserlo
la verità è che non è così in realtà il
nostro cervello non è fatto per fare due
cose contemporaneamente
neanche noi donne peraltro non ci si
crede quello che facciamo in realtà e
sbucciare cioè alterniamo
velocissimamente avanti e indietro ogni
frazione di secondo quindi capite lo
stress la cosa più grave è che più ci
distraiamo e più vogliamo essere
distratti e questo perché il nostro
cervello lo sappiamo mai per certo da
una quarantina d'anni e plastico per
tutta la vita
e cosa significa cioè che cambia cambia
strutturalmente cioè fisicamente e
funzionalmente a seconda di come lo
facciamo lavorare e noi negli ultimi
tempi lo stiamo allenando a pensare ea
comportarsi così come sull
da un link all'altro ci vuole molto meno
tempo di quello che noi immaginiamo per
riprogrammare i circuiti del nostro
cervello un'ora un'ora al giorno per
cinque giorni di fila su internet io
credo che in questa sala
nessuno di noi stia su internet per meno
di questo tempo questo signore qui si
chiama gary small è un professore
dell'università della california di los
angeles ed è stato il primo al mondo a
scoprire otto anni fa che cosa succede
nel nostro cervello in risposta all'uso
di internet
questa è l'attività cerebrale di una
persona che non ha mai svolto ricerche
online e questa è l'attività di una
persona che avete ha molta esperienza
con internet vedete che il doppio e
questo perché perché online
ci sono un sacco di cose interessanti
noi dobbiamo continuamente
velocissimamente decidere su cosa
cliccare e questo stimola sviluppa una
parte del nostro cervello che si chiama
lobo frontale che è quello deputato al
problem solving alla capacità di
prendere decisioni che una cosa buona
per carità
il problema è che più tempo noi passiamo
a svolgere un determinato compito più
noi rinforziamo i circuiti neurali che
controllano quel compito è più nello
stesso tempo indeboliamo i circuiti che
non utilizziamo più è come se noi
andassimo in palestra tutti i giorni a
fare pesi e facessimo tutti i giorni
pesi però solo nella parte superiore del
corpo alla fine avremo dei bicipiti e
torace pazzeschi ma poi non camminiamo
più tra i circuiti che stiamo perdendo
molto preziosi sono quelli che hanno a
che fare con la nostra capacità di
leggere
vi ricordate i bei tempi in cui
leggevamo un libro in cui stava amore
assorti nelle pagine per vedere come
andava a finire quella storia
la maggior parte di noi
io sicuramente vi garantisco era una
grande lettrice facciamo fatica ad
andare oltre la seconda pagina anche
quando quello che leggiamo che
appassiona ora io lo so cosa state
pensando
vabbè non riesco più a leggere anna
karenina in compenso
quello che trovo online e tagliente
stimolante è talmente interessante che
va bene ci ho guadagnato
purtroppo non è la stessa cosa leggere
nella bulimia della rete o leggere
invece su carta questi sono gli occhiali
che si chiamano ai trekking e servono
per catturare la nostra pupilla e
tracciare su device quello che stiamo
leggendo
ecco questa è la nostra questo è il
nostro sguardo mentre leggiamo su carta
vedete noi seguiamo parola per parola
riga per riga ogni tanto tornava
indietro ma tendenzialmente non saltiamo
di blocchi guardate invece che cosa ci
succede quando leggiamo online per
esempio un giornale ecco il nostro
sguardo diventa una specie di pallina
impazzita di flipper andiamo così avanti
indietro alla rinfusa apparentemente
diciamo anche un po a caso stiamo in
media 10 secondi su ogni pagina web e
addirittura c'è hanno visto un percorso
privilegiato quando leggiamo online e
cioè leggiamo le prime righe poi andiamo
velocissimamente saltiamo tutto il
blocco finale e dritti come diffusi
andiamo alla fine online
siamo un po come le api no prendiamo un
po di parole qua un po di parole la un
po di contenuto dall'altra parte ma la
differenza delle api non imponiamo
niente anzi
possiamo dirlo leggiamo ma non capiamo
oppure capiamo molto poco o ancora più
grave
capiamo quello che vogliamo capire
guardate i dati sull'analfabetismo
funzionale che significa non riuscire
più a capire profondamente quello che
leggiamo non riuscire più ad elaborarlo
ea utilizzarlo fanno paura e fanno
impressione anche i dati sulla
percezione distorta che noi abbiamo
delle cose e questo perché perché il
nostro cervello
il nostro cervello lui questo signore è
vero è vero che si modifica molto
velocemente ma i suoi processi di
apprendimento il modo in cui impara sono
gli stessi di 15 mila anni fa quando più
o meno avevamo appena scoperto il fuoco
cioè lui ha ancora bisogno di ridondanza
ha bisogno che gli ripetiamo più volte
le cose sennò non capisce e questa cosa
è grave perché vi dicevo prima della
percezione ecco voi sapete che noi in
italia
pensiamo per esempio che gli immigrati
siano quattro volte di più di quelli che
sono o che il numero degli omicidi sia
aumentato negli ultimi 20 anni quando in
realtà è diminuito anzi è quasi la metà
allora tutto questo voi capite molto
pericoloso perché noi le decisioni che
prendiamo le decide prendiamo in balzo
in base a quello che sappiamo in base a
quello che percepiamo e in base a quello
che siamo
c'è una cosa che mi hanno ripetuto
tantissimo in questi mesi in cui mi sono
occupata di questi temi e che mi ha
molto colpito perché secondo me noi non
ci pensiamo mai tendiamo a
sottovalutarla
e cioè che noi siamo biologicamente
quello che viviamo le nostre esperienze
le persone che incontriamo i libri che
leggiamo le emozioni che provo
le domande che ci facciamo è questa cosa
non me l'hanno detto i filosofi poeti
me l'hanno detto i neuroscienziati cioè
ciascuno di noi è il risultato dei
cambiamenti subiti dal cervello durante
la vita
ora che cosa vogliamo essere diventare
guardate queste aree blu sono quelle che
si attivano nel nostro cervello quando
non facciamo niente quando sono dei
momenti che gli studiosi chiamano di
riposo cioè dei momenti in cui non siamo
focalizzati su nulla in particolare in
cui lasciamo andare i pensieri
eppure il nostro cervello sta lavorando
sta facendo la sintesi di tutto quello
che noi abbiamo che lui ha incontrato
durante il giorno e sono momenti
preziosissimi perché durante questi
momenti che noi costruiamo la nostra
memoria la memoria è qualcosa di molto
fragile non è semplicemente ricordarci
quello che abbiamo mangiato l'altro
giorno ho la data di napoleone quando in
atto ma è quella che ci permette di
avere un'opinione è quella che ci
permette di avere un libero arbitrio che
fa sì che tu mi parli io ti rispondo
perché dentro di me ho la conoscenza o
la risposta se stiamo tutto il giorno
connessi se stiamo tutto il giorno a
chattare questi momenti di riposo non ci
sono più
queste aree blu non si accendono
svaniscono e svanisce quella cosa
guardate che è molto importante che
siamo noi cioè la nostra identità ora
per fortuna ci dicono gli scienziati non
c'è nulla di irreversibile ma è evidente
che più andremo avanti più sarà
difficile tornare indietro
li volevo dire questo che quasi metà
della di noi non ragiona più non usa più
le strutture logiche per pensare
stiamo diventando soltanto delle persone
reattive persone che reagiscono agli
impulsi senza analizzarli senza più
metterli
discussione abbiamo creato un mondo di
risposte che noi crediamo a portata di
mano dove tutto è cliccabile tutto è
downloadabile ma non è così e lo
sappiamo tutti
perché c'è una vita la nostra che è
complessa e ha bisogno di tempo
io vorrei terminare con una parola la
parola bellissima da cui abbiamo
cominciato che attenzione l'attenzione è
molto diversa dalla nostra
ta l'idea di concentrazione
concentrazione è un restare focalizzati
un chiudere il campo mentre l'attenzione
è etimologicamente apertura e volgere il
nostro animo verso qualcosa e verso
qualcuno
l'attenzione è veramente il dono più
grande è la forma più pura e più rara
della generosità per cui mi avete
dedicato più di 18 minuti della vostra
attenzione e di questo li ringrazio
[Applauso]
[Musica]